i really love how weird marvel went with
her fantastic forecasting
i wonder who the alligator's playing
choosing to open your show with a nausea
inducing shot
do you want me to paint the screen with
my bowl of lucky charms i just scarfed
down marvel
because this is how you get ants i mean
lucky charms vomit look carms mitt
also there's a great amount of
transitory effort put into this opening
sequence and it makes you feel like
something important is about to happen
but it's just that cleverly repackaged
previously on that points a glaring
arrow at the insane convenience of
loki's introduction in the void in its
variant loki inhabitants
what is this place where are we who are
you this is the void that's goliath
and where his lunch come on richard e
grand exposition is the best exposition
it's clear to the point and concise but
every time i see richard e grant i'm
reminded that not enough people love
hudson hawk
so also i wonder how anyone knows the
monster's name is eliath
it's not like it stops for a chat to
introduce itself before annihilating
time junk
this is it isn't it this is where you
dragged me after you stole my life
yes but can we back up a smidge and
discuss how they arrived at this place
maybe we could have forgotten that last
week's episode ended with sylvian
rinslayer down in the timekeeper's lair
but you just reminded us of it in the
previously awning a moment ago
so sylvie's hair should be wet and you
both should be on that set and not
this set i can help you if you trust me
and despite all reasons sylvia offers up
a tim pat as a symbol of her trust
even though rinslayer never asked for it
and certainly hasn't done anything to
earn it
but we gotta get the show going folks
only one more episode left
i'd like to suggest we take a quick
breather so i can ask several thousand
questions so i'm gonna keep moving so we
don't die meaning these new loki's were
on their daily keep moving stroll
through the massive
not nyc earlier and just happened upon
our loki
tv are dicks sending people out there
into the whatever verse with no tread on
their shoes
why do you wear the horns kid loki is
not wearing horns he's wearing what
could be best described as feathers
classic loki is wearing horns but arloki
isn't speaking to him i would say i'm
confused but that would infer i care at
all about this storyline
and or this show and i do not i killed
full
kids oh look it's yellowjacket helmet
and weathertop
what does it all mean also i'd like to
take a moment of silence for all the
marvel fans who've had to watch this
episode 90 times in order to find and
research all the easter eggs in this
one episode it's like the writers
realize that they could run through the
comic book buffet and scoop a little bit
of everything onto their tray
some of it's obvious like throg here
some things need a more keen eye i honor
you all with this silence in in the time
that none of us will be able to retrieve
after going down all the easter egg
timelines
so why did you want to return to the tda
so badly anyway
better question how is this underground
bowling bunker getting power supply from
anywhere we know where you hide actual
footage of me attempting to have
bathroom alone time somehow makes its
way into the episode
well except with a smartphone and a
plunger so everything she's holding is
taken to the void but
not the weapon that saps her how does
that work holy sh
if you drink an alcoholic beverage you
risk pregnancy i mean obviously the
writers drank too much roxy wine before
writing the government warning and meant
to say that drinking alcohol
while pregnant causes issues or maybe in
the pruned roxy versus drinking alcohol
does cause pregnancy is this an easter
egg a clue
damn it mcu tell me your story loki
nobody wants to hear about that
he's not wrong although i may be willing
to listen to a story if it includes the
part about how his costume design
evolved to this after kermit in a dueser
merged design houses
polybius perverts play by producing
psychoactive permutations purposely
placed by pandering policy poo faces who
push psychological programs without
punishment allegedly
have any of you met a woman variant of
us
sounds terrifying that's racist i'm
gonna kill elias
and i could use all the help i could get
character gives a rousing speech and it
seems like everyone listening is
invested but after it's over they all
burst out in laughter cliche
loki was told early on that there have
been multiple variant loki's and no two
are alike so
why are there others that look like tom
hiddleston well all the loki's have
different strengths as far as the powers
are concerned they all appear to act
about the same
so what else could no two alike mean
other than appearance
opting to break glass rather than climb
through the hole immediately above your
head having to waste my time looking up
whether or not skinny's pizza was an
easter egg and even if it was it's most
likely a car's reference since lightning
mcqueen is driving the car
so this thing can be for wasting time on
pointless research or having to watch a
car's reference
i'm giving two because i'm annoyed oh
look a working car driven by mobius with
enough
gas and off-road abilities to easily
drive here right on time to save sylvie
mad moby is fury road
how exactly can one loki name another
loki despite them being essentially the
same being
how do you bite the hand off of a god so
illusion kadoki throws illusion aligoki
on numaboki and what i find most
interesting is that aluja alagoki seems
to tackle maboki with ferocity and
substance
so is the alligator an illusion is it
real it seems very real which is
exciting because whatever
kermoki does with his power should
literally hold up and not crumble
approaching goliath is a death sentence
we'll get you to it but that's as far as
we go how is that helpful
loki can find goliath just as easily as
these other two can this show is making
it hard to root for a character played
by richard e [ __ ] grant
and i watched a little vampire because
of him the little vampire
i guess when you think the ends justify
the means there's
not much you won't do politics what does
loki need a blanket for
he was birthed by frost giants one thing
he should never get is cold
tell you what you could conjure me a new
outfit you have no idea how
uncomfortable something like this is
so don't wear it i don't even know what
we're doing
great that makes two of us skip
conjuring a communal blanket for someone
without explicit consent
and i think if i can get close enough to
it i can enchant it
and it's going to take me to whoever's
behind all of this this works
go kermoki go do some badass
mustard diaper we are here for it with
that being said if he has this kind of
juice in him why would he wait until now
to use it this would have been super
helpful back at the game of thrones
i think we're stronger than we realized
oh how i love marvel in their blah blah
blah approach to answering important
questions
i don't know how you do
because we're the same much of the
premise of this show has been no two
loki's are alike and now it's betting
that all loki's have the ability to do
anything that their variant persons can
do problem is though that even the
loki's themselves seem to forget their
existing powers for example
our loki is already enchanted and
kermoki should walk through a portal and
escape eliath
you'll understand if i don't come out
from the shadows my identity will be
safest if you never see my face
when a shark tank so for those reasons
i'm out
you said it's a living thing you said
it's a shock
i find him for three but i'll catch him
and kill him
for 10.
well life's a beach and then you drive
[Music]
you'll never find them not before she
does
and why is that you only want it she
needs it
that doesn't make sense